Sono innamorata folle pazza di un futuro
prete ed è un c***o di guaio, è un c***o di guaio perché
c'è stato un bacio
Ripeto non è ancora prete....eh nulla sono
sono molto molto disperata, perché purtroppo
lo vedo tutti i giorni ed è, ripeto, un c**** di guaio
Ti prego aiutarmi, che devo fare? E ti
prego non rispondermi farti suora
Intanto la parola c***o è stata usata parecchie volte accanto alla parola prete. Si infatti non
bisognerebbe però... Allora, io grazie al
cielo ho un passato di catechismo
cresima. Anche io. Si pure tu? Sisisi assolutamente si. Ah è vero si lo so
Ho una considerazione da fare. Ok sentiamola. Prima di tutto io una chiacchierina con questo
ragazzo la farei. Decisamente!
Soprattutto nel momento in cui c'è stato un bacio
Ma, se tu credi di avere una
vocazione nei confronti della chiesa
insomma, sotto quel punto di vista e
quindi pensi anche che quella che tu hai
ricevuto è stata una chiamata di Dio,
non pensi allo stesso tempo che sia
proprio Dio invece ad averti messo
questa ragazza davanti per farti dire
"Aspetta un secondo, non sei da meno!" Esatto! Se invece decidi di vivere una
vita laica con una ragazza. Potrebbe
essere. Se le vie del Signore sono
infinite, io questa la vedo anche un po' come
un'autostrada sinceramente. L'amore non è
una tentazione capito del male
In bocca al lupo eh. Tienimi aggiornato, fammi sapere come vanno le cose. Oppure fatti suora
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata di "Vita Buttata"
Il tema della puntata di oggi è "La posta delCuore"
Adesso fino ad oggi Vita Buttata è sempre
stato un contenitore nel quale si
scherzava, si rideva, si facevano battute,
ma fondamentalmente ho sempre pensato di
provare a trasformare Vita Buttata anche
in un posto nel quale fare chiacchiera
Ve lo metto in grassetto quello di oggi
è un esperimento che in realtà volevo fare
da un sacco di tempo, ma ho aspettato
proprio questo giorno per poterlo
mettere in pratica, perché ho pensato di
vedere in che modo Vita Buttata può
evolversi e in quante cose possono
essere racchiuse all'interno di questo format
Detto questo per una puntata così speciale ho pensato di invitare all'interno degli studios di casa mia
una persona che ha reso questo giorno,
vorrei dire meno traumatico
ma a me San Valentino fa proprio schifo
*parole incomprensibili*
Esatto, sto parlando di Luigi
Ciao. Il giorno di San Valentino per me è
un giorno inutile. Quando ero single
io vedevo le coppie fidanzate  che uscivano fuori
e pensavo "Oddio che schifo!". Adesso che sono
fidanzato penso "Oddio anch'io sono tra loro, che schifo!"
Ma perché queste smancerie? Troppe risultano...Noi pure faremo delle
smancerie però a San Valentino, quindi
insomma, predico bene e razzolo male...
dal 1987.
Allora siamo pronti? Via! Spero che le
nostre considerazioni non siano infinite.
Poracci! Cioè se guardano il Signore
degli Anelli e fanno prima. Si leggono la
Bibbia e fanno prima, leggono un trattato
di psicologia sulle relazioni di coppia
e fanno prima. Risolviamo i problemi di cuore
Ciao Gu  ciao ospite, io ho bisogno di un consiglio
perché sono fidanzata da nove anni in casa, quindi anche con la famiglia
però mi sono accorta di non amare più il mio fidanzato ormai da, non so, forse tre anni
Avevo intenzione di lasciarlo, ma non so come fare.
Se mi date qualche consiglio ne sarei molto
ve ne sarei molto grata, quindi ciao
Oddio su ste robe io non sono proprio bravo. Io si
Questa è tosta. Questa è da trattare con i guanti di velluto. Ti voglio un attimo aprire gli
occhi su quello che accadrà qualora tu
dovessi continuare a comportarti in
questo modo. Ipotesi a, passeranno altri 5,
6, 7, 8 anni, 9,10 farete dei figli e tu
sarai per altri 7, 8, 9, 10 anni un infelice
che sta insieme a una persona che alla
quale sicuramente vorrà un bene dell'anima
ma che allo stesso tempo non riesci ad
amare, perché non puoi scegliere la
persona che ti attrae. Qui non c'entra un
discorso di cattiveria però è molto
importante in questi casi il modo e le
modalità. Quello che ti dico io è,
l'ipotesi b potrebbe essere ancora
peggiore che vivere una vita infelice,
ossia, passa un anno, passano due anni e
mentre fai la spesa ti innamori
follemente di qualcuno che ti fa fare
la c****a così grande per cui tu a un certo punto
brutalizzi il tuo ragazzo, lo mandi a c****e
all'improvviso e ti fai una vita con
questo qui perché? Perché tu hai tutti
questi anni di frustrazione alle spalle
per cui automaticamente incominci a
diventare insopportabile, scontrosa,
perché? Perché speri che la scelta la
faccia l'altro di mollarti. No. Quando
succedono cose importanti bisogna anche
comportarsi in maniera importante e
secondo me la persona che il tuo
compagno vorrebbe al proprio fianco e
vorrebbe che gli facesse questo discorso
sei solamente te. Quindi il mio consiglio
è, prendila alla leggera. Non serve per
forza dire "Senti è finita", ma anche
incominciare a aprire questo discorso e
spiegare magari anche che sei disposta a
metterti in gioco, perché la cosa più
brutta è farsi un'idea di una persona e
poi di colpo avere una persona che ti
sveglia con l'acqua fredda e renderti
conto che in realtà tu per gli ultimi anni
sei stato solamente a immaginare
un mondo che non esiste. Io sono sicuro
che anche se non ami più questa persona,
tu nei suoi confronti nutra una forma di
amore, magari diverso da quello iniziale.
Ecco, appenditi a quello e vedi di non rovinare
quella roba lì e vedi di trasformare
quella roba lì in un ponte. Ti ho detto che so bravo
Mi hai stupito, bravo. Però è la cosa migliore. Sono d'accordo. Bravo bravo bravo
Cioè non c'entra una cattiveria, la cattiveria subentra nel
momento in cui ti comporti male
Allora ciao Guglielmo, non so cosa regalare alla mia
ragazza per San Valentino. Ti dico
soltanto che l'anno scorso siamo
riusciti a regalarci la stessa
identica cosa. Carino però. Un peluche di
un porcospino. Però ho pensato, visto che ti segue tanto lei
e potenzialmente tu potresti leggere
e rispondere a questo messaggio vocale
perché non essere tu il regalo di San Valentino
Allora cara S...aspetta che cerco un fiocchetto.
No no non voglio un fiocchetto. Cara Sara
l'anno scorso hai ricevuto un peluche,
pensavi che il tuo ragazzo non potesse
scavare più in basso? E invece ci è
riuscito, Mattia ce l'ha fatta, perché il
tuo regalo di San Valentino nemmeno lo
riceverai, perché è un video, un piccolo saluto
da parte mia e... buon San Valentino, auguri. Ciao ragazzi
No posso dire che questa cosa però dei
regali è terribile. Mattia senti una sola cosa
ma mi fai un video invece per lui e
così sei tu il regalo di San Valentino
perché io non ho idea.
Ciao Gu, volevo dirti che io sono stata lasciata
due mesi fa, prima di Natale, perché dopo
due anni di relazione lui ha deciso
che nel suo futuro si vede da solo e che
non voleva più stare con me non perché
non gli andassi bene ma, mi ha proprio detto
"Non prenderla sul personale ma io voglio s*****e in giro". Ciao
Bella, bella m***a! Terminare una relazione dopo un mese, due anni, 5, 10
non è un crimine. Non state facendo
qualcosa di sbagliato, però dipende tutto
da come lo fate e dai motivi che
date. Prendere in giro una persona con la
quale essere stati è una cosa veramente
brutta e soprattutto aver il tatto di un
rinoceronte. Quindi per favore potete prendere
esempio dalla storia di questa ragazza
per capire qual è almeno una delle
tante cose che non dovete fare?
Dimostrate proprio di non avere un
minimo di p***e.
Guarda ti posso dire una cosa veramente col cuore
una persona che dopo due anni ti
dice una cosa così ma veramente ma
buttala via, perché se dopo due anni
questo è il rispetto che riesce a darti
queste sono le motivazioni che riesce a
darti, non è veramente fatta per stare
insieme alle persone, non è manco fatta
per stare insieme con se stesso. Te lo credo
che poi di deve perde tra le gambe della
gente. Il fatto che tu ci stia male è
normale e mostra che sei una persona
normale che ha un collegamento con la
propria emotività e con i propri
sentimenti normale e fluido
Che schifo. Camuffare la voce, quante voci
camuffate, quante persone che non
vogliono far sapere. Quando si tratta
d'amore. Bravi ragazzi mi piacete così subdoli
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, per questo episodio di Vita Buttata volevo raccontare la mia tragica situazione
in cui io sono una ragazza molto, molto, molto, molto,
molto alta, quasi due metri
Di conseguenza la mia difficoltà sta nel trovare letteralmente qualcuno che sia alla mia altezza
quindi ti volevo chiedere un consiglio anche
perché effettivamente ci potrebbe essere
qualcuno in questo momento che mi interessa,
cioè il mio migliore amico. Cosa si fa in questi casi?
Non ti lasci scoraggiare da ste
robe
nel senso, se uno ti piace e magari siete
sulla stessa linea d'onda, ragazzi che vuol dire
No facciamo invece una cosa più utile. Ragazzi all'ascolto
se siete sui due metri, se siete alti mi
scrivete, oppure segnati tipo a pallavolo
basket in modo che la squadra maschile
solitamente rasenta i sette metri e mezzo
secondo me Hagrid, potrebbe essere
un'altra mossa, cioè basta aspettare che
le api vengano al miele, ma buttiamo
il miele in quell'alveare
Sono d'accordo, bravo, ottima dritta. Il mio ragazzo a
San Valentino ha deciso di andarsi a
vedere la partita di pallone allo stadio,
così ho dovuto annullare il ristorante
già prenotato. Lo ammazzo, lo lascio, e dammi un
consiglio. Vi posso di na cosa? Io sono dell'idea
che la metà della mela non lo troverai
mai, anche perché due metà di una mela
non possono attaccarsi, a meno che non ci
metti del bostik. Tu devi cercare
l'altra metà del puzzle,
a incastro devi andare capito?
Quindi deve essere ovviamente una persona
diversa da te, perché altrimenti non si
crea l'incastro, una persona però i cui
difetti tu riesci a sopportare
Poteva andare a vedere un'altra il giorno di
San Valentino. No le cose importanti
sono altre però magari una ragazza sai...
si ci sta, però mi sembrava sorridente
No ma infatti ci ride sopra da sola...Ammazzalo... e secondo me c'è anche passata sopra
In pratica io ho 17 anni, da un paio d'anni ho scoperto di essere gay e mi vergognavo prima di
dirlo o da poco ho avuto la forza di dirlo. I miei amici, scusa se senti l'affanno
ma ho fatto le scale proprio ora e sono appena tornato dalla palestra, quindi sono stanco
La mia vita sia amorosa, sia non, non è stata molto semplice
e comunque da poco che ho scoperto di essere gay c'è un ragazzo che mi piace, ma non so come dirglielo
perché non ho il coraggio di fare coming out davanti a tutti, e vorrei dei consigli. Un bacione
Partiamo dal presupposto che a 17 anni sei molto giovane...Esatto
ed è quindi normale che tutto quello che ti
stia capitando sia ancora una novità ed
è la cosa meravigliosa dell'avere la tua età. Goditele. Allo stesso tempo, primo
questo ragazzo siamo sicuri che sia gay?
Secondo, questo ragazzo siamo sicuri che
sia affidabile? Perché se non sei pronto
a uscire così allo scoperto io te lo
sconsiglio sinceramente per questa cotta
e per questa curiosità di buttarti in
una nave che non può reggere le onde. Io ho
avuto un sacco di cotte al liceo e
per le tue stesse paure,
io non mi sono mai diciamo esposto, non ne ho mai parlato
perché comunque era una cosa
nuova e ancora non sapevo esattamente
come gestirla. Il mio invito... di darti tempo...il mio invito è quello di darti del tempo
senza contare che esistono un
sacco di modi, un pochino più sicuri
per incontrare persone senza doverti per
forza così esporre o anche per
confrontarsi con altre persone.
Se vuoi correre allacciati prima le scarpe
una volta che ce le hai allacciate allora puoi fare quello che ti pare, ma non pensare al
traguardo se stai a piedi scalzi. Mamma mia. Ragazzi.  Ma che cosa sta succedendo?
Secondo me è stata la pancarré con burro d'arachidi. Con i 27 chili di burro d'arachidi
Qualsiasi cosa tu dovessi scegliere in
bocca al lupo...e goditi tutto, sul serio ...perché
sei giovane. Cioè nel senso ancora di cose che dovrai farne. Ti spezzeranno il cuore, perderai la testa
troverai l'amore, le
cose andranno bene, le cose andranno male
E' bellissimo in realtà. Ho fatto ora un discorso da vecchio. Si, ma lo sei, dentro e anche fuori ultimamente
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, che immagino sia una donna
SI
diciamo anche bionda, alta, magra, occhi azzurri. Bella! E invece sarà un uomo. Scusa il
sottofondo di camion, treni, aerei.
Più che un consiglio vorrei chiederti un piccolo favore
in quanto il regalo che vorrei fare
o diciamo una piccola sorpresa che vorrei
fare al mio amore è quello appunto di un
un tuo messaggio di auguri. Trovo sia una
cosa originale, che non si può comprare da nessuna parte
Quello che volevo chiederti appunto, se potresti essere
tu a fare gli auguri alla mia ragazza
che si chiama Francesca. Ci terrei tantissimo e so che la lascerebbe a bocca aperta
quindi niente, attendo una tua risposta e magari
di vederlo nel tuo video. Grazie mille
Ah io mi chiamo Alex, così se nel video lo
vuoi dire, si capisce anche meglio. Ciao ciao
Allora. Ci vuole un fiocchetto ti prego fammelo cercare. Non voglio un fiocchetto! Ti prego
Cara Francesca, ma in questi casi non si canto tanti
auguri a te? No, è San Valentino
Cara Francesca, che dire, Alex, il tuo fidanzato,
ti voleva mandare un messaggio tramite
questo video, per dirti che ti ama tanto,
che sei il suo amore, che cosa carina
molto, e per dirti che ci teneva a
regalarti qualcosa che non si può comprare
Il che vuol dire che non può manco restituirlo. Dove pensi di andare? Sono in imbarazzo
Godetevi la serata,
datevi tanti bacetti carini e
promettetemi tante cose belle... e
mantenetele... soprattutto, queste cose belle e
soprattutto il tuo ragazzo è molto molto
simpatico, molto, fa troppo ridere, quindi
tienitelo stretto. Guarda che gli uomini
così sono rari, rari, so finiti
Capisco Alex, infatti siamo veramente
in pochi Alex
Era una battuta
In tal caso mi dispiace Francesca. Allora ragazzi, io
direi un secondo, visto che questo video
sta andando molto molto per le lunghe, di
prenderci una pausa, chiuderla qui e
dividere questo video in due parti.
Quindi se volete maggiori informazioni
su quando uscirà la seconda parte di
questo video guardate qua sotto nell'info box
in modo da poter rimanere
aggiornati. Buon San Valentino, che possa l'amore...
Se no veramentei, cioè non finiamo più ragazzi, non finiamo più. Grazie... al c***o
No, ai messaggini. Grazie. Ciao